downtown is a whole lot tastier thanks
to the guys at saginaw's delicate
delicatessen over at the circa hotel and
we have two special guests today we have
owner of saginaw's paul saginaw to tell
us more and we also have jeremy
rosenfeld the culinary director to teach
us all about the deliciousness that you
guys serve there first of all tell us a
little bit about saginaws you're out of
michigan and you're here in las vegas
now how'd you make that move uh well uh
back in 1982 with a couple partners i
opened a delicatessen in ann arbor
michigan zingerman's delicatessen uh and
that's where in ann arbor where the
university of michigan is uh derrick
stevens the owner of circa went to
school there and used to eat at the
delicatessen
and about five years ago i got the email
equivalent of a cold call and it said
hey
i'm derek stevens i own the golden gate
in the d and i got some things brewing
and i think i have an opportunity for
you to bring your bran out here and i
said well we don't take our bran out of
ann arbor but i love las vegas what
problem are you trying to solve i'd love
to work on it with you well we're so
glad you did and you guys are going to
teach us about one of your most famous
sandwiches here the reuben okay so
give us a lesson in the art of sandwich
making here
okay well
to have a great sandwich you have to
have a great bread
we get our bread baked fresh every day
at bond breads
by the master baker carlos
we brought our rye recipe to them and it
took about 18 months to get it to work
in the atmosphere of las vegas which is
much drier and the water is a lot
different
the bread comes fresh bake every day but
then we double bake it we put it in the
oven for about eight to twelve minutes
at 3 20 we want to get a hard crust on
the outside we want it warm and chewy on
the inside
and that's how you start out with the
great bread now that looks good i love i
love the diagonal cut you had on that
there paul is there like a method to
your madness on that
yeah you definitely want to open up the
bread and cut nice and on a diagonal
bias that way you get better surface
area for the whole sandwich itself see
we're learning something okay what'd you
just spread on there so first we start
with our olive oil it's our extra virgin
olive oil nice high quality there
next we're gonna go with our house made
russian dressing
the russian dressing has 11 ingredients
in it all top secret russian dressing
recipe that paul has in his head oh did
you just come up with that yourself uh
well you know
nobody comes up with things all by
themselves we all borrow from each other
but we certainly modified this quite a
bit
uh and you know the reason it's called
russian dressing is because originally
it was made with caviar whipped into it
we've got some cheese going on there
we've got 30 seconds left i want to make
sure we get this next we go with our
swiss cheese there okay and then we have
our sauerkraut of course can't go wrong
with the sauerkraut no and this meat
looks so good
what is that pastrami that's corn beans
corned beef okay which is similar but
different okay you can make a
pastrami reuben too absolutely okay we
do have that option available at the
restaurant as well all right and then
man that's a lot of meat all your
sandwiches like that all of our
sandwiches piled nice and high need two
hands to eat then
you can do this at home very easily
and then just smash it on there just
smash it on there grill it nice and
golden brown on each side cut it we
serve it with our fresh house made
potato chips
and our really great dill pickles we
have old dills and new dills one's a
little more sour than the others one's a
little closer to a cucumber and there's
the finished product you guys see that
you can check out saginaws at the circa
hotel
what does matthew mcconaughey say when
he takes a bite of his reuben and
everything comes out
all right all right all right yes
we're gonna send it over to you